Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Eighteen, Part Two.
Smoking is the biggest single cause of illness and death in Denmark.
About 16,000 people die each year as a result of smoking.
That is more than every fourth death in Denmark.
To get people to smoke less, it has been forbidden to smoke indoors in public places, that is places where there is access for everyone: for example public transport, sports halls and cinemas.
It is also forbidden to smoke at workplaces and schools and in by far most restaurants, cafés, bars and discos.
Pupils in folkeskoler and in youth educations, for example upper secondary schools and vocational schools, are forbidden to smoke during school hours, also outside the school's area.
In addition cigarettes and other tobacco must be hidden away in shops so that they cannot be seen by customers.
In 2019, a political majority agreed to raise the price of a packet of cigarettes from about 40 kroner to 55 kroner in 2020 and further to 60 kroner in 2022.
Furthermore, in recent years there has been increased focus on mental health and psychological disorders and illnesses.
The Danish Health Authority's survey, "The National Health Profile", shows that the Danish population overall has good mental health.
More and more Danes over 16 do, however, state that they have poor mental health, from 10 percent in 2010 to 17.4 percent in 2021.
The development in poor mental health is seen especially among young people aged 16 to 24.
Among women in this age group, the share who experience poor mental health has risen from 15.8 percent to 34.4 percent and among men from 8.3 to 21.1 percent in the period 2010 to 2021.
The Danish health service.
It is the regions, regionerne, that are responsible for running by far most of the health service.
The regions run the hospitals, sygehuse; the municipalities and the state do not run hospitals.
Police are the state's job and kindergartens the municipalities'.
That applies to the hospitals, which are free for patients.
And the regions give all citizens resident in the country the right to free help from a general practitioner and a specialist doctor, as well as grants towards, among other things, treatment at a physiotherapist, dentist, psychologist and the purchase of medicine at the pharmacy.
The general practitioners, specialist doctors, physiotherapists, dentists, psychologists and others are self-employed business people.
They are, however, paid wholly or partly by the regions.
It is thus free to go to your general practitioner, who is the entrance to the health service.
By far most citizens are registered with a regular general practitioner, who is also called "own doctor", egen læge.
In most cases the general practitioner finishes the examination or treatment of a patient themself.
But the patient can also be referred, sent on, to a specialist doctor in private practice, for example a dermatologist, surgeon, gynaecologist or neurologist, or to a hospital, if the general practitioner assesses that there is a need for it.
In recent decades many hospitals have been closed down in Denmark.
Instead, treatments have been gathered in far fewer, but in return bigger, hospitals.
An important purpose of this merging is to achieve higher quality in treatment, because the doctors and nurses can get greater experience and routine with complicated treatments, and because the large hospitals can better afford to buy the newest and best equipment.
This development has however also triggered some dissatisfaction in parts of the population, because many towns have lost their local hospital and thereby also jobs, and because a large part of the population has got a longer distance to a hospital.
While hospitals and general practitioners are free, there are also parts of the health service where patients pay wholly or partly themselves.
There are for example grants when you buy prescription medicine, but part of the amount, up to a limit, you must pay yourself, egenbetaling.
As a main rule you must also pay part of the bill yourself when you go to a psychologist.
But there is a grant for certain patients if their doctor has referred them, for example because they have been victims of a serious accident, attempted suicide or have anxiety or depression.
Dental care, tandpleje, is free for children and young people up to and including 21 years.
After that there are grants for certain examinations and treatments, but the patient's own payment for dental care is generally high.
The municipalities also have responsibility for part of the health service, not least for taking care of the sick after they have been discharged from hospital, and when it comes to preventing diseases.
It is thus the municipalities that are responsible for, among other things, care and rehabilitation after hospital admission, and also home nursing, treatment of alcohol and drug abuse, child and youth dental care, social psychiatry and prevention, including offers of help to stop smoking.
Here is your recap for Episode Eighteen.
The health service made up 9.4 percent of the economy in 2025.
Life expectancy, middellevetid, was about 40 years in the 1800s; in 2024 to 2025 it is 83.9 for women and 80.3 for men.
Average height has grown from about 165 centimetres for men and 155 for women to 180 and 167.
Reasons: more food, medical science, hygiene, and a health service.
Over 100 hospitals were built in the late 1800s and early 1900s; the state gave grants to sick funds from 1893; the sick funds lasted until 1973, when public health insurance replaced them.
Lifestyle diseases include cancer, cardiovascular disease, diabetes and COPD; severe overweight rose from 5 to 6 percent in 1987 to 19 percent in 2023.
Unskilled workers live five to seven years shorter than academics.
You must be 16 to buy light beer, øl, of 1.2 to 6 percent and 18, atten år, for cigarettes, strong beer, wine and strong spirits, stærk spiritus; in nightlife zones 18 after 10 pm.
Smoking kills about 16,000 a year, more than every fourth death.
The regions run most of the health service: hospitals, free general practitioners and specialists.
Dental care is free up to and including 21 years, and child and youth dental care is run by the municipalities, not the regions.
The municipalities handle care and rehabilitation after hospital, home nursing, treatment of alcohol and drug abuse, child and youth dental care, social psychiatry and prevention.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
What are the regions responsible for running?
Option A: The police.
Option B: Hospitals.
Option C: Kindergartens.
[DA] Hvad har regionerne ansvaret for at drive?  A: Politi  |  B: Sygehuse  |  C: Børnehaver
The answer is B: Hospitals.
It appeared in the June 2020 and June 2022 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Sygehuse
Question 2.
Who has the main responsibility for running the hospitals?
Option A: The state.
Option B: The regions.
Option C: The municipalities.
[DA] Hvem har hovedansvaret for driften af sygehusene?  A: Staten  |  B: Regionerne  |  C: Kommunerne
The answer is B: The regions.
It appeared in the May 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Regionerne
Question 3.
Who is responsible for running child and youth dental care?
Option A: The municipalities.
Option B: The regions.
Option C: The state.
[DA] Hvem har ansvaret for driften af børne- og ungdomstandplejen?  A: Kommunerne  |  B: Regionerne  |  C: Staten
The answer is A: The municipalities.
It appeared in the November 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Kommunerne
That's the end of this part.
Well done.